some might say is it that helpful to
undermine the prime minister at this
stage of negotiations well we're at the
stage now where Parliament is expecting
and anticipating the government
machinery the full weight of the
government sheet machine to put all its
pressure on MPs to agree the deal and
the full force of the scare mongering
around project fear and if Parliament
doesn't agree that and I really don't
think that's an acceptable choice this
choice between a deeply flawed deal
that's going to leave us effectively as
a vassal state to the rest of the
European Union with no control at all no
say in the rules that are going to
control a huge swathe of our economy
that's wholly unacceptable versus the
chaos of No Deal I genuinely think it's
time to pause and to take stock of the
alternatives that are there on offer
what this deal shows is that a huge gulf
has now opened up between the lavish
promises of an idealized brexit that
were made during the referendum campaign
versus the poultry reality of this deal
we were promised an ability to strike
trade deals far from it we will have
very limited ability to strike
meaningful trade deals of our own we
were promised that the UK was going to
become a tiger economy on the edge of
Europe actually we're signing up to a
common rule book which we won't control
which will be the same as all the rules
currently applying across the rest of
the European Union and we were promised
that this was going to bring back
control take back control in fact the
reality is with ceding control we have a
shared say at the moment in the EU rules
that govern the single market we will be
subject to them entirely without any say
at all in future it's a travesty of the
referendum result and that's why I think
it's so important that we now go back to
the people and check that this is indeed
actually the brexit that they want both
you and your brother have now resigned
from government orbit with very
different viewpoints do you not think
you're better off influencing from
within where does this leave you now
well there comes a point where you have
to take a stand and we're now hours days
maybe maybe days maybe hours away from
this deal and it's really important that
we begin this urgent debate about the
alternatives because as I said I do not
think we're being being presented as a
parliament and as a country with
right choice it cannot be a choice
between a wholly inadequate deal that
leaves us in a sort of vassal state
relationship to the EU or no or no deal
at all and the chaos that that will
bring there are alternatives and I think
it's absolutely vital that we now
explore those and we use the mechanism
of a referendum to do exactly that
so why now mr. Johnson you could have
resigned months ago some might say that
you've resigned now to inflict maximum
damage on the prime minister at this
crucial stage in the country I
campaigned for remain in the referendum
but I accepted the result I voted for
the article 50 process to start and I've
kept my piece for two years more than
two years to allow the Prime Minister
the maximum possible negotiating space
not to limit her maneuver room for
manoeuvre I haven't spoken up before but
we're now at the point where MPs like
myself are going to have to take a view
is this deal in the national interest or
not it's clearly inferior than our
current relationship within the EU
prominent leave campaigners including my
brother have said that it's inferior as
a deal to our current membership of the
EU so on what basis could we possibly
agree to it you supported at the
referendum you voted for article 52 be
triggered why now have you decided that
it's the best time to change your mind
well as I said I've given the Prime
Minister the full period of time two
years to do her best to secure a deal
that's in the national interest as I
said I voted for article 50 to commence
this process I respect the referendum
result but we're now at the point where
MPs need to take a view is this deal in
the national interest or not and in my
view and in the view I think of others
it clearly isn't it leaves us in a
vassal state client relationship to the
rest of the EU with no say at all over
the rules that will govern a huge swathe
of our economy that's completely
unacceptable and unsustainable for a
prior democracy such as ours now in your
resignation yesterday you talked about
how brexit has divided the country it's
divided at politics it's divided
families as you know only too well
what's Christmas gonna be like in the
Johnson household
look there are political differences we
disagree about brexit but actually we
have a shared analysis on the
limitations and the profound flaws in
the deal that the government is about to
put before Parliament it leaves us in a
client state relationship with the EU
it's got a massive Democratic deficit in
it which in my view is completely
unsustainable for a democracy such as
ours what realistically do you hope to
achieve by your resignation number 10
have been unequivocal there will not be
a second referendum of any kind what
could you possibly hope for now well of
course number 10 would say that wouldn't
they I mean government policy is always
government policy until it isn't if you
cast your mind back to last year when
the Prime Minister and number 10 were
ruling out a general election will in
fact we ended up having a general
election notwithstanding all of the
repeated assurances that it would be
against the national interest to have
one so take that with a pinch of salt if
Parliament wants a referendum the
legislation can be passed quickly and
the Electoral Commission could could
advise on the nature of the question and
so on but if there's a will away can be
found and your thoughts on Dominic Raab
the brexit secretary who said on
Wednesday I hadn't quite understood the
full extent on this well I'm not going
to comment on those those remarks
directly what I would say from my
experience in the Department of
Transport is that the complexities of
managing no deal from a freight
perspective are profound we would face
major bottlenecks on key arteries going
to our core channel ports this would be
a very very big setback for the
manufacturers whose just-in-time supply
chains depend on them being able to get
parts in and out of the country
seamlessly so do not underestimate the
damage that a No Deal would do to our
economy and that's why I think this
choice that we're going to be presented
with the prime ministers deal flawed as
it is or the chaos of No Deal it's
completely unacceptable there are better
options and we must explore them now
just lastly our story today that senior
min
have briefed the Prime Minister on a
secret plan amid fears there will be no
deal if her withdrawal deal is not voted
through in Parliament what do you know
about that do you know anything about
this secret plan no I'm not aware of it